All right. Hello, everybody.
Sorry. We're going to go ahead and get started.
Good afternoon, and welcome to this mini symposium on integrative
computational approaches. My name is Dimitrios Tsiodras.
I'm an assistant professor at Johns Hopkins in the Department of Oncology, and it's
a pleasure to co-chair this session with Dr.
Andrea Sotiriva, Head of Computational Biology at Human Technopole.
We're really excited for today's talks, and we thank in advance our speakers
for sharing their work, and thanks for everyone for being here today,
both in person and virtually, to participate.
I've been given a couple of minutes to quickly set the tone.
So I'll just start by saying something that I think is probably pretty
obvious to everyone in this room or
those who attended the previous session here in this room.
We're in the midst of a data revolution in cancer research.
And this largely stems from us now profiling patient
samples across multiple novel modalities,
multi-omics, genomics, transcriptomics, proteomics,
providing us with diverse high-dimensional data streams to work with and learn
from.
And at the same time, I think it's interesting to observe, and you'll see in
the talks as well, how we're increasingly extracting
signal that's complementary from data types that we've had for
decades, like histology, radiology, clinical records, EMRs,
that we're now recognizing as deeply information-rich.
So altogether, this creates a new reality in which a major bottleneck is less
central to data generation and more central to integration
and interpretation at scale. So in other words, how do we
create robust, coherent, and comprehensive,
meaningful biological models? So that's what this session is about, and
today's talks
address this problem from complementary angles.
We'll first hear from Dr. Boehm on advances on representation learning and
digital pathology, and then we'll continue a streak of wonderful talks
from Doctors Zhao, Lo, and Ene on how single-cell and spatial
multi-omics,
and even radiomics combined, show that tissue organization is
important for both biological context and also predictive of
outcomes. Then from Dr. Sokolova, we'll see how deep learning models
can shed light on clonal cancer evolution. Dr.
Zhang will show examples of integration across biological modalities
to better resolve cell lineages and cell states.
And finally, we'll slightly switch gears with Dr.
Lahul,
who will show how foundation models can be applied to model PMHC interactions
and unlock new forms of immune engineering.
And what I think connects all these efforts is the shared goal to move
beyond siloed analyses and towards systems-level
understanding of cancer and cancer treatment that spans from
molecular landscapes to tissue architecture to mechanisms to patient outcomes,
and ultimately build robust computational frameworks that yield
actionable biological and clinical insights.
So with that, let's just get started with our first speaker, Dr.
Boehm, who's a post-doc in computational oncology and a resident in radiation
oncology at MSK, and he is the recipient of the AACR
Margaret Foti Foundation Scholar in Training Award.
All right. Thanks, Dimitri, for that nice introduction.
Thanks, everyone, for being here. Good afternoon.
Here are my disclosures.
Let me see if this goes any higher. Okay.
So how do we identify cancer subtypes in clinical practice?
It's really an integration of anatomic and histopathologic
information. Shown here is a subset of the OncoTree
ontology, where starting from cancer, one can think about the
source of an anatomic site from which a specimen is taken, and
then further sub-specify based on cellular investigation
of the topology of the cellular morphology under the microscope and
identify, for example, colon adenocarcinoma.
And it's not
a new idea to apply AI to help identify tumor subtype and to
help in this diagnostic process. Shown here are two
examples, paradigmatic examples, using genomic
information, the GDANS classifier by Mike Berger and Quade
Morris' group in Madison Darmafal on the left to use clinical
sequencing to help identify the source of metastatic
tumors. And on the right, some work by Faisal Mahmud's group
using histopathology, deep learning on histopathology, to identify
the source of a tumor.
And more recently, of course, cancer subtyping has understandably
been a benchmark task for the development of different
foundation models, both at the tile and the whole slide image level.
Occasionally, beyond the child nodes of the tree that we looked at a couple slides
ago, there are molecular features that further determine a characteristic
phenotype. And the best known of these is, of course, microsatellite instability in
colorectal cancer, which yields a distinctive phenotype,
effectively
corresponding very tightly with the molecular features and allowing for
identification of that from the H&E image itself under the microscope.
And there have been many studies as well identifying these
features and whether they exist. Shown here is some work by Alex Pearson and
Jakob Cather. I would say this was the first flagship in the
field, and there have been many follow-up studies since,
looking at different cancer types, say, for example,
pancreatic cancer, finding that KRAS mutations are associated with a
characteristic phenotype as identified by black box deep learning.
So in this study, we set out to control for detailed tumor subtype,
harnessing a large dataset,
to identify what role digital pathology has as a complement to, rather
than just as a surrogate for, clinical sequencing as applied to
the screen for phenotype-genotype as well as cancer
subtyping.And the schematic overview for this is shown here.
From the parts used for MSK Impact clinical sequencing,
we looked at the scanned H&E whole slide images,
and identified black box tile-level features
using our custom preprocessing package that we forked from Faisal
Mahmood's Clam package, and extracted these tile features to
train two supervised learning models on top of this.
On top is AEON, a cancer subtype inference model
that uses structured knowledge from the NCI Thesaurus Knowledge
Graph to infer from the H&E whole slide image and
anatomic site and other covariates,
124 detailed tumor subtypes.
And the second row shows Paladin, our suite of models that
condition within each tumor subtype and site,
primary or metastatic, to infer the presence of a molecular alteration.
And really, we formulated this as the test of the null hypothesis that there exists
no relationship between the phenotype on H&E and
the molecular feature of interest.
On the bottom are some details about our data.
For the sake of time, I'll just say we had about 350,000 whole slide images from
about 60,000 cases that we used for train, test, and
validation internally, as well as multiple external test cohorts,
including a new cohort that we curated with Alex Pearson's group at University of
Chicago, the OncoPLUS sequencing panel, as well as TCGA and
others shown here.
So getting right into the results, on the left is the knowledge
representation of the different tumor subtypes based only on triplet
embeddings from the NCI Thesaurus Knowledge Graph.
So for example, looking at this brown island, we see this tight
nested network of different nodes in the central nervous system,
and more distally, we see these peripheral nervous system
tumors like malignant peripheral nerve sheath tumor connecting into neuroblastoma,
effectively reflecting
the concepts of the different tumors that we then bake into the cross-entropy in
the model.
On the right are actual data. These are the representations of the
MSK test set, where each dot is an embedding
of an anatomic part from the H&E and the covariates, and it's colorized by
the ground truth pathologist-labeled diagnosis in the OncoTree ontology.
And empirically, the
average one versus rest AUROC across the 124 classes
is quite good at 0.996.
We next set out to compare AEON, our H&E-based model, to
GDENS, the genomics-based classifier.
And as you might imagine in the primary setting, it's a much easier
task. In the background, you have all of the original organ, for example,
benign breast tissue, so it's easier for the H&E.
We see good performance for AEON in blue
overlaid by green, the multimodal integration of AEON with GDENS using
both the genomic and the histopathologic information.
We do see a performance gain with the multimodal integration in the external
primary validation
and also in the metastatic test set internally.
We also benchmarked AEON against, trained on the same
data,
inference of the OncoTree code using Titan with
the covariates or Chief and found that
the performance was as shown here, with AEON performing the best when trained on
the same data.
This also holds for rare subtypes.
Can't get into all the details with such short time, but I just wanted to show you
an example of the ovarian granulosa cell tumor.
Of the 11 in the test set, AEON correctly identified nine of
them as granulosa cell tumors, and the other two it identified as
similar histologies, gastrointestinal stromal tumor and ovarian
carcinosarcoma.
Next, moving into the inference of different molecular features from the
H&E conditioned within each subtype.
We investigated genomic features at different scales, at
single nucleotide variant level, at the gene level, at the pathway level, and at
the whole genome level, shown here in this heat map, where each row is a
specific histology, most of them OncoTree codes with a couple of exceptions,
like we sub-stratified for receptor status in invasive ductal
carcinoma of the breast.
And this heat map is obviously complicated, but it's best read by, for
example, going to the row for uterine endometrial carcinoma and going across
until you get to your feature of interest.
Let's say that we're interested in microsatellite instability, and you go to the
box, which is divided between primary and metastasis,
and you see that on the upper left, it's this darkest red, which corresponds
to an AUROC in the test set of between 0.9 and 1.
Here's a list of some of the top-performing features.
Unsurprisingly, colon adenocarcinoma, microsatellite instability, previously
described, is tightly correlated here.
We also found
some less
well-described inferences like SDK11 and lung adenocarcinoma or
BRAF V600E, microsatellite stable carcinoma, adenocarcinoma of
the colon.
We also benchmarked against DeepHistology and found
that Paladin outperformed in most cases where we could benchmark
directly, and we also swapped in several different choices for a foundation model
to investigate how sensitive Paladin was to this and found that compared to our
initial configuration with H Optimus Zero, none of them
outperformed. For example, swapping in Titan didn't improve the
performance.
We also looked at some previously reported phenotype-genotype associations using
the more coarsely aggregated cancer subtypes.
Say, for example, in pancreatic adenocarcinoma and neuroendocrine
tumor combined together, we saw that both
in previously reported literature and in our recreation of this, that the
inference of multiple endocrine neoplasia 1 variants was
almost perfect. However, adjusting for subtype, we found this abrogated the
signal down to not significantly different from random,
suggesting that this is simply more associated with more granular clinical subtypes
rather than a characteristic phenotype within the neuroendocrine
tumors.We next set out to look at
three different ways in which Paladin can further enhance the value of sequencing
as it becomes increasingly available in the clinical setting.
First, we noticed that in cases with oncogenic alteration, that the model
score was really minimally associated with a cancer cell fraction.
You see here that the inferred oncogenic probability
does
statistically significantly associate with the cancer cell fraction, but it's quite
a similar distribution across the three tertiles.
So we looked at the inference of APC
alterations in cases that were marked by pathologists upon MSK Impact as
extremely low purity and flagged for this and identified a
prognostic signal based on dichotomizing the Paladin inference of APC
alteration,
suggesting that possibly, pending further validation, there could be
something to this.
We next identified in SDK11 that there were certain variants of unknown
significance that had much higher inferred probability of an oncogenic
alteration of a loss of function in SDK11 compared to others.
So we selected a subset of this, took them to the lab, and with our collaborators,
Natasha Rakhtman and Jason Chang, performed immunohistochemistry against SDK11
to actually assess the function. And you note here in
these example fields of view, this has retained SDK11
function, this has loss. In cases with lost
SDK11,
the median score interquartile range was significantly higher
for the Paladin inference of SDK11 loss of function compared to those with patchy
or retained SDK11 loss of function, neither of which were inferred to have that
from the H&E from Paladin.
Finally, we set out to look at phenocopying.
So looking at SDK11 cases, now none of which had a
detected alteration. So variants of unknown significance are not included in these
three groups. We have oncogenic here, and then these two groups are
wild type, but dichotomized by the H&E-inferred probability of
having SDK11 loss of function, and we noted a survival difference between the
two.
Moving to a separate cohort in the TCGA, we looked at the wild type cases,
again dichotomized by the median score with the Paladin
inference from the H&E, and noted dramatically
reduced
mRNA expression for SDK11 in those that were inferred to have SDK11 loss of
function, on par with
cases that had
whole exome sequencing-detected truncating mutations.
One other example that I'll show to close out is in urothelial carcinoma of the
bladder, there's this well-described raisin-oid phenotype by
Hikmat Alhamadi and Dave Solid and others that's present in those with
FGFR3 oncogenic alterations. So we
looked at, again, wild type cases, again dichotomized by the Paladin score.
So those that were inferred to have an FGFR3 oncogenic
alteration had, first of all, higher FGFR3
expression on RNA-Seq. And then we collaborated with Hikmat to
take a look at these cases under the microscope and identified that all those cases
but one exhibited the raisin-oid phenotype, where we blinded him, of course, to the
identity of the cases. Whereas neither of these two, even though they had
high RNA-Seq expression of FGFR3, exhibited
that phenotype upon pathologist review.
So in conclusion, I hope I've shown you that digital pathology methods can
identify tumor subtypes across 124 detailed subtypes, and
supervised learning still has value if you have a large data set with
granular annotations.
Most molecular alterations don't associate with characteristic phenotypes, but
about 4% do. The exception that proves the rule, I should say.
Some previously reported phenotype-genotype associations were confounded by the
coarse aggregation of subtypes by anatomic site.
And digital pathology has some complementary value to clinical
sequencing in four ways that we discussed today: identifying phenocopying
states, aiding with the annotation of variants of unknown significance,
potentially identifying variants in very low purity samples pending further
validation, and improving tumor subtype classification when you
combine it with H&E in the metastatic setting.
I have a lot of people to thank, many of whom are here in the audience,
friends, thought partners, but I have to give a shout-out to my mentors,
Nikki, Saurabh, and Francisco. Thanks, and happy to take any questions.
We have time for a couple questions. Please go to the mic.
Jimmy Frau, biologist, but I love AI.
So I'm in the Cone Pharmaceutical in Boston area.
So I have two naive questions, basically for the AI.
So
usually we talk AI is you talk about a specific model
you generated,
and another talk about AI is just public, like ChatGPT.
Mm.
So for this kind of analysis, first question is, can
we use ChatGPT? If no, why?
If yes,
the second question is,
advantage and disadvantage between two?
Yeah, definitely. I think what you're getting at is the use of foundation models,
which we certainly made use of here.
I think that there have been some benchmarks of pathology-specific foundation
models that are tuned on in-domain data, outperforming more generalist models
such as ChatGPT, but I haven't seen a benchmark like that in at least a year,
so the data might have changed. I think the real reason not to just
upload your picture into ChatGPT is that if you think about these for downstream
use cases, you really need performance guarantees on the model.
And having a supervised learning where you can get confidence intervals and have
withheld test sets is really important.
You can do that if you want with prompt engineering in ChatGPT, but I think the
approach is pretty cognitively similar.
Thank you.
Yeah, of course.Omar
Hi, Kevin. Congratulations on this great work.
Thanks.
Really, really foundational, I believe, because you just show
for which genes there's a phenotype/genotype connection that can be found on a huge
data set. What I was wondering about, and I wasn't sure if I completely got it
from the presentation, is do you believe that with the current technology, within
that 4% subtype where there is a correlation, can we
differentiate between allele-specific mutations within genes?
And is this something that would be possible from your data set, something you
looked at?
Allele-specific mutations?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not something that we've looked at yet. It's definitely on the list.
I think this is sort of the initial screen that we would start with at the scales
that I showed. But yeah, it's definitely an open question.
I don't have the answer, though.
Perfect. Thank you.
Yeah.
So, we'll move on to our next speaker.
Great. Thank you, Kevin.
So next we have Julia Lowe, a PhD candidate in computational
biology at Duke.
Hello. Hi, everyone. Thank you for being here. Thank you for the introduction.
My name is Julia Lowe. I'm a first-year PhD student in computational
biology and bioinformatics at Duke University, and today I'm going to be speaking
about my project, developing a model for glioblastoma recurrence
prediction that involves a multi-omic approach but is centered around
histopathology.
So a quick background for the cancer type we're studying.
Glioblastoma is an extremely aggressive brain cancer with a median
survival of less than two years. One of the biggest clinical
challenges is that recurrence timing varies widely from patient to
patient. Traditionally, when patients are diagnosed with glioblastoma, they receive
a surgical resection, be treated with chemo and radiation, but it almost
universally comes back. So the main key question we're trying to answer
is, can we not only predict recurrence, but understand why some patients live
much longer than others? And we use multiple modalities because each provides
complementary information to help decode this question.
The first modality that we're working with is H&E slides, which can convey general
information about tissue architecture, cellular density, and structure,
as well as any sort of histologic heterogeneity patterns.
And this is a very inexpensive, routinely collected modality, and thus is highly
scalable. The other modality on the far right here are MRI images, which
provide a whole tumor view of the tumor,
conveying information about overall structure, size, any edema, as well as
uncover imaging biomarkers, and this is also routinely collected in the clinical
setting. In the middle here, we're leveraging two different types of spatial omics
data. The first being Xenium, which is single-cell resolution in situ
gene expression, as well as Codex, which is single-cell protein
expression. And this can provide very rich data about cell identity,
different transcript and proteome programs, as well as functional activity.
However, these are not very accessible types of modalities to be working with.
They're quite expensive, and the access to them is not universal across all
labs here. So thus, the goal of my project is to incorporate information
from all of these modalities, but focus my algorithm on the types of data that
is routinely collectible in the clinical and research setting.
So, a quick overview of the architecture of the proposed model.
The main goal is to develop this prediction model that's centered on the routinely
collected and available data, like the histology and the MRI images, while
utilizing the richness that spatial data can provide as more as an
explainability metric, as opposed to a direct input to the model
itself. So we'll start with these H&E whole slide images, incorporate relevant
clinical metadata, as well as features derived from MRI scans, which we'll
treat as patient-level covariates in the model.
And for each of the H&E whole slide images, we perform tile extraction to
generate non-overlapping tiles from the whole slide image, and we feed it into
a pathology foundation model, specifically Uni2 model, which we'll
later fine-tune specifically for the task of recurrence prediction.
And where the spatial data comes into play here, the Xenium and the Codex data,
again, not as an input to the model, but rather for explainability.
We can align this to the histology data that we have to get a better and more
comprehensive picture of what's going on on a transcript and proteome level.
So once we have the alignment of the spatial modalities, we can fine-tune the
foundation model by adding an attention head specifically for the task of
recurrence prediction, where we can identify tiles within the H&E whole
slide images that are implicated in recurrence timing.
And the output to the model not only would we have a fully functional pipeline to
develop a time-based to a recurrence, but also
developing a more biological understanding of how recurrence
manifest, and the mechanisms that drive recurrence, and why they're different from
patient to patient.
A quick overview to the cohort. We're starting with a very small
sort of preliminary data set to set up the overall structure of the algorithm.
So right now, I have 19 patients that are newly diagnosed GBM patients, all
of whom received a total resection in their first primary surgery.
Fifteen of these patients received standard chemo and radiation
therapy, and four of these received, again, standard chemo and radiation,
but in addition, a PD-1 inhibitor.
And we have quite a variety in recurrence timing across each of these patients, as
well as from different areas within the brain.
And so I grouped the initial 19 sample cohort into three different groups based on
recurrence timing, the short recurrence group, the intermediate group, and the long
recurrence group. So right now, we're currently expanding this cohort, but this
just represents preliminary data to set up the framework of the model.
And now I'll get into some of the analyses I've done on each of the modalities
independently. So for our 19 sample cohort, we had a neuropathologist at
Duke review and annotate each of the slides for areas, for example, of
necrosis, tumor core, infiltrating tumor.
And what we've seen from this preliminary analysis is that samples that
have quite poor clinical outcomes, they have very short time to recurrences,
display increased architectural disruption.
While on the other end of the spectrum, samples that retain a much longer time to
recurrences, we see clear segmentation and normal tissue
architecture is more so retained.
So we see quite clear areas of vasculature in other regions all the way on the
right here, while on the left we see quite a large disruption in tissue
architecture.The algorithm that I'm using to generate my tiles
is called SlideFlow, and the reason we want to do this is because H&E images are
quite large and contain millions and millions of pixels, and by dividing them into
these non-overlapping tiles, we can introduce them to a machine learning
framework that the model can handle.
So how this works is by overlaying a grid on top of the H&E images, and we'll
filter out any sort of background or out-of-focus or artifact regions, and
each tile represents a particular piece from the H&E whole slide
image.
Once we have each of these tiles, we can leverage the richness that foundation
models can provide. So here I'm using the UniHeal foundation model.
For my 19 samples, I generated the tiles for each of those, and then each tile is
fed into the Uni encoder to generate embeddings.
And then once we have the embeddings from all of the tiles, I've processed them and
constructed a
clustering graph here. So in the UMAP here, all of the tiles are
represented by belonging to each individual cluster.
And what I've done is assigned the cluster identity for each of the tiles,
mapping back to the H&E whole slide images to see if they represent any sort of
biological pattern and can be conserved across the cohort.
For example, you can see cluster zero, which is the top one in the key here.
This dark blue corresponds to regions annotated by the pathologist
as
necrotic areas. So we see that the foundation model can sort of capture
biologically meaningful trends.
And how we're going to fine-tune the
pathology foundation model specifically for our task of recurrence prediction, we
start with having the H&E whole slide images that we use to attract pixels
with, feed them into a foundation model, specifically UniHeal.
And the early layers of the model will capture more general, broad
histologic patterns, so things like cellular density, broad morphological
patterns, and we'll freeze these early layers to
make sure that all the information the pathology model is capturing represents
these high-order features. The later layers will be
unfrozen. These are the trainable layers, which will extract biologically
relevant and niche information that you wouldn't be able to pick up with your eye
alone. We'll then add an output head specifically for the task of
recurrence prediction. And we can visualize the results of this fine-tuning through
three different metrics, the first being a saliency map, which shows which
pixels were implicated most in terms of driving model
predictions. We can also use the gradient-weighted class activation
mapping to identify which regions were most important in driving model predictions,
as well as in attention map visualizations to see which tiles are most implicated
in terms of recurrence differences.
So this is how we'll visualize which areas corresponding to the H&E whole slide
images are most important in terms of recurrence differences.
Now I'll get a brief introduction into the MRI approach that we're using.
So for the MRI images, the first step involves pre-processing these, aligning the
different sequences, removing any non-brain tissue, segmenting the tumor
within the MRI to three different regions, whether it's the non-enhancing tumor
core, the enhancing tumor, or outer edema and infiltration.
We then calculate pixel value features and use a pyRadiomics pipeline to
extract radiomic features and then perform feature reduction, as there could be
quite a lot of features. And the main goal here is to identify features
that aren't traditionally used in imaging biomarkers.
So obviously, a patient that has quite a larger tumor is expected to have a
worse clinical outcome, and we're trying to uncover more niche and
non-traditionally used features.
So here we're currently in the process of extracting radiomic
features for our cohort,
and like I said before, we're trying to uncover things that aren't traditionally
used in radiomics pipelines and reveal which features can be
picked up that are important for driving differences in recurrence.
Going quickly into the spatial omics analysis, a key issue we're
running into with our current cohort is that the Xenium and the Codex data that we
have are not collected from serial tissue slices from the same tissue
block, and thus we have to figure out a way to best align these two modalities
because they provide complementary and very useful information.
So I'm using an algorithm called MaxFuse, which is designed to align these weakly
aligned spatial modalities, and how it works is by creating a cell-to-cell
mapping between each of the modalities that leverages both the shared
features among the two modalities as well as all of the features from each
of the different modalities, so we can better understand which cell from each
modality is best aligned with one from the other modality.
And the reason I'm interested in doing this is, for example, is to classify
different subtypes of immune cells because transcriptomics alone in our current
panel that we're using for Xenium can't distinguish, for example, lymphoid cells,
CD4 versus CD8 T cells. However, the protein markers are
much more specific and stronger and can provide more classification for
distinguishing these types of cells.
And we're currently in the process of generating the rest of the Codex data of our
cohort, but preliminary results suggest that samples with a longer recurrence
timing have enhanced immune activity, while samples with shorter
recurrence timing have a more immunosuppressive environment.
And we're currently expanding this cohort as we're running the Codex for the rest
of the samples.
And now I'll quickly get into how we're leveraging the sort of integration
of all of these modalities together.
So since we have the H&E images as well as these rich spatial modalities, we
can align them together onto the same coordinate system, so we can understand, for
example, how cells spatially co-localize with different morphological regions on
the tissue itself. We can also compute tile-level gene
program scores. So for each tile extracted from the H&E whole slide image,
we can look at whether each of the tiles are
more geared towards a particular tumor
cell subtype. So here I've listed the different classifications of
GBM tumor cells, and we can figure out
what the different gene program
scores within each tile to understand on a transcript level what's going on
in this morphological tile.And the last analysis here that I'll
cover is through the process of spatial domains.
So I used a K-means clustering approach to define 12 different spatial
niches and did a differential gene expression analysis here.
I found in niche eight here, which is an oligodendrocyte-enriched niche,
we found increased immune engagement in samples that had longer recurrence.
While samples that had shorter recurrence, interestingly, had a lot of genes
upregulated in myelination and specific cell lineage programs.
And you can see in the gene ontology analysis all the way on the right here, this
is showing programs upregulated in the short recurrence group that we see a
lot of upregulation of neuronal ensheathment and myelination in oligodendrocyte
development. So again, this is on a small cohort, but we're working to expand
this and see if these claims hold true on a much larger cohort.
So the next steps for this project would be to expand the cohort
size. Here, I've listed the various sources that we're expanding
through additional histopathology images and spatial modalities.
And then once we have quite a large enough cohort, executing this model
for driving recurrence prediction, as well as identifying features that
are most important in recurrence differences.
And then the main goal of this is to sort of democratize the use of spatial
modalities by being able to infer different gene expression and
protein expression patterns from histopathology when in the case that
spatial data is not available. And the long-term goal would be to expand an
algorithm like this to additional cancer types.
For example, we're very interested in brain metastases originating from breast
cancer.
And then I just want to give a quick thank you to everyone in my lab who's here
with me, as well as my collaborators. And happy to take any questions.
While people are moving to the microphone, I'll ask
a question. So you're
combining multiple diverse modalities and the outputs
of multiple foundation models. You briefly
mentioned you're thinking about feature importance.
So how do you ensure that your model will learn complementarily,
and
how will you flag maybe redundant representations?
Yeah. So integrating different spatial modalities is a
challenging topic, but I think the main goal of this approach is to focus
on the information that we can glean from the histopathology and the other
modalities, whether it's the Xenium or the Codex.
Like I said before, not a direct input to the model itself, but rather for
explainability. So it's less so of a multi-omic integration
and focusing on one particular modality and using the others as
metrics to get a more comprehensive understanding of the biology
driving these model predictions.
All right. So how robust do you expect your model to be with
respect to
changing treatments? If you have multiple trials with many treatments,
and there aren't that many GBM treatments that succeeded-
Mm-hmm
... but if you had to go and look at failed clinical trials and go back and see
if you wanted to predict recurrence versus not,
so how robust do you think the model would be?
Yeah. So the
ideal situation would be that all patients receive standard chemo and
radiation.
But we would account for it as sort of a covariate in the model by whichever
adjuvant therapy it received. But there's no way to control
the sample collection in terms of what treatment they received.
So, ideally, we would have standardized treatment across the cohort, but if not, we
would account for it and see how that implicates the overall survival or recurrence
timing.
All right. I think we're out of time. Thank you again, Julia.
Thank you.
I'll introduce the next speaker, Dr.
Faming Zhao, postdoctoral researcher at OHSU.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Faming Zhao from Oregon Health & Science University.
Today, I will present our recent work on deciphering single-cell
heterogeneity and cellular dynamics during prostate
cancer progression.
This is my disclosure information.
As we all know, prostate cancer progression is a continuous
multi-stage process from
localized prostate cancer to metastatic state
and therapy-resistant state, and
ultimately
to NEPC. Notably, NEPC is an aggressive
lineage prostate cancer state associated with poor survival
and limited treatment options.
In this progression
often happen with a complex TME.
And in this TME,
including several cell types, including
epithelial cell, stroma cell, and immune cell, and those
cell can dynamically interact with tumor cells.
And
while single-cell technology provides important insight
into cellular heterogeneity, several key
challenges remain. For example, the current studies
are often limited by small sample size, and they are still
lack of unified cross-stage
atlas that can capture the whole stage
of PCa progression. And second,
the understanding of immune and the stromal ecosystem remains
incomplete.
And finally,
the spatial organization and
progression-associated niche is
poorly defined.
So to address those challenges, we provide a
unified single-cell and spatial framework to map cellular
ecosystem across PCa progression.Here we
first build a large scale single-cell atlas integrating 19 data
sites and greater than 700K cells across
the four PC spectrum. And then we
integrate this single-cell atlas with
spatial transcriptomic data and other independent
cohorts to map spatial organization and
clinical relevance.
Taken together, our work provide comprehensive results to
study how tumor cell and multicellular ecosystem
evolve during PC progression.
Here we first
define the epithelial cell landscape across PC progression.
Here we identify multiple distinct
epithelial states. Then we use inferential analysis to
identify malignant cell and non-malignant cells.
Here we found that basal, hiloch, and caliber
cell are primarily non-malignant cells.
Meanwhile, luminal and other unrelated states are
largely composed of
malignant cells.
We next characterized the functional programmers of
epithelial state. Here we found the basal, hiloch,
and caliber cells showed
inflammatory and immune
program grammars with low AR and
low activity.
Meanwhile, unrelated states show the aggressive
futures and increased positivity with
reduced AR signaling.
Moreover, we identify key
TF and tuple markers for each epithelial state.
Then we observe a distinct enrichment
pattern across PC stage. And we found
those epithelial states associated with different
clinical outcomes. Together, our results show that
epithelial cells have continued towards lineage positive state
during PC progression.
We then next explore how the immune ecosystem evolved during PC
progression. Actually, we found that advanced PC
not only alter tumor cells, but also reshape the immune
ecosystem toward
immune suppressive state.
Here we first analyze T and NK cells.
Here we identify diverse T and NK cell states.
Among them, we found the second T cells
showed significantly enrichment with PC
progression.
Importantly, second T cells showed features of
dysfunction and exhaustion.
In addition to second T cells, we also
found the Treg cells and two exhausted
CD8 T cell states have a significant enrichment
in advanced PC, suggesting a progression
of enrichment of dysfunction and immune suppressive T cell
states during PC progression.
In addition to TCL dysfunction, we also
explore the myeloid compartment evolved during PC progression.
Here we identify a broad diversity of myeloid
cell states across PC stage. Among them, we note
SP1 positive macrophage
expanded in advanced PC.
And besides, we found the SP1 macrophage display a
clear M2-like phenotype with
reduced M1-associated features.
This was validated by our PC mouse
models.
And spatial analysis shows that SP1
macrophage are
co-localized with Treg cells and
exhausted CD8 T cells and MKALFs.
Together, those results show that SP1 macrophage are associated
with localized immune suppressive niche in advanced PC.
We then next explore the clinical relevance of SP1
macrophage. In our PC cat atlas, we
found that SP1 macrophage are enriched in lymph node
metastasis. This suggest potential
involvement in early tumor determination.
We then ask
whether this pattern can extend to distant
PC metastasis at particular bone, because
bone is the primary site of PC metastasis.
So using our in-house,
match the treatment-naive, primary and
bone metastasis
single-cell data cohort,
we found that SP1 macrophage are significantly enriched
in bone metastasis. This is validated
by our UWTMA cohort
using cycling IF staining.
Notably, we observe
SP1 macrophage are associated with poor clinical
outcomes, highlighting their potential clinical relevance.
Next, to evaluate the functional role of SP1
macrophage, we use bone metastasis mouse
model.
Based on this mouse model, we found that
anti-SP1 treatment reduced tumor burden
and reduced cancer-associated pain.
Notably, SP1 inhibition significantly prolonged the
survival of mouse.
Taken together, those results suggest that SP1 is a
promising therapeutic target in advanced
PCIn addition to immune
cell remodeling, we also observe some change in the
stroma compartment during PCa progression.
Here we identify diversity
of stroma cell population. Among them, we found
mCAF expanded during PCa progression,
and actually mCAF showed a significantly
EMT state.
And
we found mCAF are associated with SP1 macrophage
at a single-cell level,
and at a spatial level, we found SP1 macrophage and
mCAFs are co-localization
in the tumor
niche.
And we also found higher mCAF abundance is associated
with worse clinical outcomes.
Those findings suggest a potential stroma myeloid
remodeling in advanced PCa.
Then we next to explore those cell population,
how can they be spatially organized?
Here we're using the spatial transcriptomics
data and cell neighborhood analysis,
integrating with our PCaCAT atlas.
Here we identified six
epithelial-enriched and five stroma-enriched
niche. Among them, we found CN1 is
a lineage positive state enriched for
AE-PCas tumor cells, and CN7 is
a mCAF-enriched stroma niche.
Importantly, both CN1 and CN7 are
associated with poor clinical outcome and
significantly expanded during PCa progression.
We then focus on CN7,
mCAF-enriched tumor stroma niche.
We further found that CN7 is
spatially close to the CN1, which is AE-PCA
like niche.
Within the CN7 itself, we found
SP1 macrophage are the most enrichment myeloid population.
Besides, we also note
CN7 is enriched with Treg and the
exhausted CD8 T-cells.
And those results are supported by our in-house The
Cosmos spatial
cohort.
Finally, we used second eye for staining
with UW-TMA cohort. We found
co-localization of mCAF and SP1 macrophage at
protein level, and more importantly, patient with higher
combined level of mCAFs and SP1 macrophage showed a
significantly worse clinical outcome.
Those results define the mCAF and SP1
macrophage centered immunosuppressive niche that is
associated with poor clinical outcome in advanced PCa.
Overall, our study provide a high-resolution reference of
tumor ecosystem and define cellular and spatial
program grammars
that shaping PCa progression.
We also develop an interactive PCaCAT
data website that enable user to explore gene
expression and perform cell type annotation.
And finally, I want to thank my current
lab members and collaborators, and
we also want to thank the patient and their families.
Thank you for your attention.
Does it work? I'll ask a quick question.
Yeah.
Do you try to correlate your single-cell phenotypes with classical
histopathological annotations such as Gleason score,
and how did it go?
Actually, Gleason score information is from the
public dataset. For our PCaCAT atlas, the
information of Gleason score is from original publication,
so we just download those information.
And for our in-house data, actually, we
have our in-house cohort, so we record those
Gleason score.
Can you repeat your question?
Yeah. So
at the single cell level, you measure all these, like stromal
composition, immune composition.
Yeah.
Did you
correlate them with Gleason score? Do you look at histological images?
Did you do any of that?
Do you think you should?
Do you want to do it?
Oh.
Yeah, thank you for this question.
Yeah, it was okay. That's fine.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you very much.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you again, Faming.
Oh, yeah, thank you.
Our next speaker is Ksenia Sokolova, a Postdoctoral Research Associate at
Princeton Precision Health.
Hello. Yes. Thank you for introduction.
I'm Ksenia, a postdoc at PPH, and I'm going to be talking about
deep learning profiling for regulatory somatic variants across clonal
cancer evolution.Unfortunately, I have no financial disclosures,
so we go right in.
First of all, to set up the conversation, what do we mean when we talk
about from sequence? So at its core,
genomic sequence can be represented as a sequence of base pairs or letters.
It forms out a large volume of books, and even if you're a very
diligent reader, you won't be able to read it, or even if you were, you're
unlikely to get much insight out of it.
So our approach, as is obvious from the title, the deep
learning approach, is basically when we have a deep learning
model that scans through the genome and predicts biochemical
molecular effects directly from the sequence with or without the
variants introduced I'm going to talk about later.
And if there's a variant there, you can infer pathogenicity of the variants
or mechanism and context, for example, gene expression
or others. Importantly, when we talk about these deep learning models, what
we want to make sure that it's been trained on the
reference sequence. So what it means is that when during training, the model
learns the regulatory patterns of the genome
without a bias of the variants or information
about these variants,
such that after the model has been trained, you can take a DNA
sequence, introduce the variant in there, run it again through the model,
get your alternative predictions, and then you can compare reference and
alternative to get your variant effects.
Which turns out to be very convenient because you can predict the effect
of any variation this way, such as a rare or
previously unobserved variance without a bias of the
previously observed variation.
And I've been talking generally about the deep learning model.
Hypothetically, the analysis I'm going to show you can be done with
a variety of different deep learning methods.
Currently, we're using the SAIE framework
developed previously at Princeton by Cassie and Jan, where
basically they have trained this model using
a large compendium of the genomic data, and where you
have the genome sequence, you run it through the deep learning model, and you get
a huge number of predictions, basically.
For a given sequence, you get over around
22,000 chromatin profiles. Some of them are cell type and
tissue specific,
and it works really well. But what's even more interesting is that
when they've been running it, they have observed that
it seems to be forming these kind of groups.
Or what they call sequence classes.
So what is possible to do is then they have run
these predictions across millions and millions of genomic
sequences from the reference genome, again, sampled randomly.
And when they cluster the sequences, they observe that they form this very
interesting cluster that seem to be forming
logically, for example, brain cancer-related
material. And so instead of looking directly at these
22,000 chromatin profiles, what it lets you do is that it lets you
to condense this information into what they have defined as
40 sequence classes, some of which are tissue or cell type
specific,
and allow you to do a much more in-depth
analysis with the ability to go back to your
22,000 precise chromatin profiles.
And what's very important and relevant, as I discussed before,
is that because it goes from sequence, you can introduce,
you can run in your reference, you can run an alternative, and basically you
can quantify the impact of any variant
on the regulatory element activity.
So for example, here you might observe that after introduction of this
variant,
the
sequence no longer is a brain enhancer sequence, but now it turns into low
activity or some other, for example, immune sequence
class.
So why have I been spending so much time on the variants?
And how do we connect these actual regulatory disruptions to cancer outcomes?
Which I'm sure more of you are interested in than the deep learning part of this.
So what we've been looking at is we take somatic variant call files, clinical data,
and tumor characteristics as an input.
And we collect this information into three bins.
One is our sequence-based deep learning predictions of the
somatic regulatory disruptions, which I'm going to talk a little bit more, but you
have seen the core driver of it being the deep learning
model. We also collect information such as
FGA, mutational burdens, and measures of genome instability, and
in addition, some clinical information such as cancer type and age.
And what we want to connect is a progression for interval, patterns of
regulatory dysregulation, and also contribution of clonal and subclonal
architecture.
So I'm going to talk a little bit more about, again, what do we do for the deep
learning prediction. And we apply this framework for over
4,000 tumors, 1,500 events, long follow-up, and again, 40
sequence classes I was mentioning.
Here, I'm primarily going to be showing results on TCGA, but we also have applied
it to the ICGC ARGO.
So when we talk about the regulatory disruption profiles.
All of the prior information I have talked about is at
the variant level. But when we're going to connect outcomes, we no longer want to
be at the variant level, we want to be able to collect this information from a
group of different somatic variants and
have some patient-level representation.
So the way we approach it is that we try to retain it to be as interpretable
as possible and let you go back directly to the variant.
So
what we do is that we look at the genes and we look at the transcription start
site proximal variants. We have used PyClone to separate clonal
from subclonal variants.
And then
for each of these variants, we run, say, as mentioned before, which produces
you 40 sequence classes, which are, again, representation of a much
bigger information that you can follow back
through.And then we pick the sequence classes that have
the highest effect as a result of the mutation, and we
aggregate them together, accounting for the total number of variants, such that
we're
not interested as much in the mutational burden as much
as in the regulatory effects conveyed by these variants.
And as a result, for any given gene of interest, we now
have this regulatory effect for this gene.
And then to further collect this information up is that we collect
predictions across the genes into this individual-level
representation. And here we're focusing currently on the hallmark
gene scores and expanding more beyond that in the
future. And then the goal of our
project is to connect to, as I was mentioning, progression-free
interval and maybe some other interesting insights.
So now that we
now have this regulatory disruption score in a
hierarchical manner. So at the core, we have the representation for each
individual person, and then we can unfold it back into genes
and from genes to sequence classes, and all the way back to the variants and very
specific transcription factors that have been affected.
And does it actually separate was the most interesting question, right?
So we directly show that regulatory disruption and specifically
severity of the disruption is associated with progression-free interval,
where individuals in the high group, so basically individuals
with a high
disruption of the regulatory activity, have much worse progression rates.
And this is, as I was mentioning, pan-cancer across many different
cancer types in the TCGA and replicating
ICGC ARGO.
And not only that, but actually we then follow up through
and we add other measures such as genome instability,
age at diagnosis, tumor mutational burden, and also the total
regulatory variant count. And no longer anymore looking at
the high or low variants, but instead just looking at the continuous
regulatory score, and even after all of these cofounders and corrections,
we still see that the severity of the regulatory score
is important for the
survival and progression, which is exactly what we want to
see. And the point
is more that it's not just the recurrence or the number of regulatory variants
that affects it, but more is the severity.
And as you can see, the regulatory variant count itself on the bottom is actually
not significant. But what is significant is the severity of the regulatory
effects.
And then we further look in
the clonal and subclonal disruptions.
The prior results I've shown was grouping all the variants together into
one score. But since we have this information about which variants are clonal and
subclonal, we can
look closer and see that not only the regulatory severity matters,
but also it matters whether it's been clonal or subclonal, and this
information is complementary to each other.
And as I was mentioning before, the total count of the
variants in either clonal or subclonal does not matter as
much as the severity of this disruption.
And when we further look back, as I was mentioning, now we can unfold it
back and we see that
when we unfold back into the genes,
we see that the variants occurring later in the
clonal evolution actually have higher regulatory scores
than happening early, which was pretty interesting for us to observe
and could be interesting to follow up in specific
cancer types. Because
this analysis is pan-cancer, we can then look back further in and see that it's not
uniform for the same cancer, that there are certain cancers for which subclonal
contribution seems to be more severe.
And then we can also, as the last part of the analysis, look back
and figure out the regulatory disruption profiles for each of the
individuals. And we see that they form a very distinct six
clusters where, say, cluster one is pretty
severe. It affects almost all of the sequence classes.
But we also see some other ones that affect only, for example, immune
sequence classes, which would be interesting to follow up
through. And then we also observe that for the genes
being affected by the specific disruption regulatory profile, they
also exhibit different pathways and different
processes involved in this regulatory disruption profile.
And so in summary, we showed that predicted severity of the regulatory somatic
variation is linked to patient outcomes and not the
number of tumor mutational burden in the regulatory space.
And there are specific regulatory programs across tumors.
So I mentioned some of the other things that we are continuously working on this
project, such as, for example, looking at some of the integration of the coding
variants. And also we are working on integration with our verifiable
agentic system. If you are curious, this is for the agentic system,
where basically we have previously worked on having
verifiable process such that you can track back all of the information
that's used in the user query in a more of an agentic
AI mode.
So yeah, a lot of exciting things happening.
And with that, saying thanks to Precision Health, the lab, my mentors, Olga
and Vessela, who are here today.
Ready to take questions.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
We have time for a few questions.
Yes.
Let's go on the left first.
Hi. That was a beautiful talk. Tim Trish, Van Andel Institute.
One of my grad students is actually transitioning from a F99 to a
K00, working on the impact of regulatory variants in
pediatric tumors. And so that sort of leads to my question.
There's a
substantial number, thanks to the Gabriella Miller Kids
Firstact from Congress,
especially as a substantial number of pediatric cancer genomes, which
obviously have a fairly low somatic mutation burden among recurring elements.
But particularly in the case of T-cell ALL, for example, it's thought that
non-coding variants may have an extraordinarily
heavy impact on the outcome of the disease.
Have you considered running
S-E-I, SEI?
Ah.
How do you pronounce that?
SEI. Yes.
SEI. All right. I noticed that it was published in "Nature Genetics" around
2022. Have you
started running SEI on some of these well
clinically characterized cases where they often have multiple time
points and some clear cytogenetic
delineation of clonality? Have you run it on any of those types of cases, and
what do you see?
Ah, that's a great question. We haven't tried it yet in terms
of the clinical established variants.
That said, pediatric cancer specifically are very interesting for us
because we look at across all different ages of pan-cancer,
and we did specifically check pediatric versus adults, and we definitely see
that
the signal might be a little bit different there.
And we do see a lot of strong regulatory somatic variants, especially for
the cancers with poor prognosis or poor
progression.
I'm looking forward to seeing it.
Yes.
Thanks for this really awesome talk. Ryan Collins, Dana-Farber.
So I noticed a couple of the clusters that you called
out, sort of say, the brain enhancers or immune
enhancers correlate with
relatively data-rich environments for training these models-
Mm-hmm
... psych encode and
Roadmap, I guess, or Blueprint having generated so much regulatory
data-
Mm-hmm
... on immune cells and on brain cells.
I'm wondering, and full confession, I haven't read the SEI
paper. I'm going to go do that after this because it seems like a really amazing
model. For rare cell types,
have you seen or have you tested how well the regulatory
effect predictions transfer to sort of undersampled or even perhaps
unsampled
domains, enhancers that might be specific to a single cell type?
Oh, yeah. That's a great point. So we have seen that the model
generally performs fairly well, but of course, you mentioned there could be some
biases to the data-rich environment.
And sequence classes help a little bit because we're no longer looking
at the specific transcription factor and specific cell type, but rather it's kind
of a clustering of different transcription profiles.
So even if one is a bit of a less profile,
overall, they usually represent this group of transcription profiles, so
it helps in that sense. But of course, it would be interesting to follow up with
that. Yes.
Cool. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
I will ask a question.
Hi. Emma from UW Madison. A really great talk.
I like the slide where you showed how the low and high regulatory
scores correlated with progression-free survival.
So do you have any information on what prior treatments those
individuals received, and you think that may be a confounder in that low and high
score? As I imagine, prior treatment history would affect
whether you have dysregulation in your genome.
Oh, yeah. That's very interesting.
Unfortunately, not all individuals have treatment.
We've tried to look into it briefly, more in the clusters of treatments such as
curative or palliative intent treatment.
We don't see necessarily a lot of signal there,
but we're hoping, so now when we're working on replication ICGC
ARGO, it has more information about the treatment, so we might try to take a
look at it.
Thanks. Thank you.
We'll get our next speaker. Thank you, Ksenia.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Chibawanye Ene, Assistant Professor at the Department of Neurosurgery at
MD Anderson.
All right. Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Chibawanye Ene.
I'm an Assistant Professor
in the Department of Neurosurgery at MD Anderson.
I actually trained as a surgeon, so a lot of what you're going to hear about is the
work from our lab that leverages
integrated spatial multi-omics approaches to
understand how to improve cell-based therapies
for glioblastoma and also improve our extent of
resection for glioblastoma, which is critical for the survival of our patients.
So a lot of what I'll talk about is mainly translational, with the help of
our very, very smart computational biologists
collaborators.
These are my disclosures. I don't get any financial benefit and compensation from
any of them. So we heard, I think several talks at
the major symposium earlier about how the
transcription of heterogeneity in glioblastoma
influences resistance to treatments, and gliomas, diffuse
gliomas in general are incurable.
Even after aggressive surgery, chemotherapy, radiation, these tumors
invariably come back, and the WHO actually classifies these tumors from
Grade 1 through Grade 4, with diffuse gliomas being Grade 2 through Grade 4s, and
glioblastoma, which is the more common one, the most common tumor in adults,
being a Grade 4 IDH wild-type tumor.
And a lot of the work that was done by several groups, including Mario Suva's
group, have characterized several transcriptional cell states that dominate
within these tumors. You can see them here.
There are four distinct cell states that dominate these tumors.
And it is believed that these cell states actually contribute to aggressiveness
when they shift from one state to the other, as well as resistance to
therapy.And most of the plasticity is actually between these two cell states, the
mesenchymal cell states and the AC-like cell states, and that drives plasticity.
And a lot of studies that have been done with 3D organoids ex vivo have shown that
in response to chemotherapy, glioblastoma cells change, shift
states, and that allows the cell type to actually go to a
less vulnerable state, a more resistant state during treatment.
Another aspect of this is that the mesenchymal cell states have been implicated in
immunosuppression, primarily through crosstalk with
tumor-associated macrophages driven by TGF-beta family members.
And so ultimately, there's a critical need to identify
strategies to actually identify these cell states
in real patients in fresh tissue before these samples actually get
sent off for next-generation sequencing.
Because if we can do that, we can track responses to treatments in live patients,
in fresh samples,
without any of the artifacts that are introduced by processing for
single-cell RNA sequencing. So
one of the intraoperative methods that we use as surgeons to
define different genomic
groups of tumors of glioblastoma is intraoperative mass spectrometry.
And here I show you
Grade 4 astrocytomas that are IDH mutant and Grade 4 astrocytomas that
IDH wild-type, which are glioblastoma.
And several groups have now shown that we can use mass spectrometry to actually
distinguish these two very clinically relevant subtypes.
And this is important because,
as a surgeon, if you know that a tumor is IDH wild-type and you're more aggressive
with your resections by taking further and further
safe margins, you can actually close the gap between survival between the IDH
wild-type tumors and the mutant tumors.
And so based on this, we hypothesized that it is possible that mass
spectrometry, if we brought it into the operating room, we could use it to
distinguish, again, the mesenchymal-like cell types, the AC-like
cell types, and the other cell states that are involved in driving glioblastoma
resistance to chemotherapy.
And so what I'm going to walk you through very quickly are some of the methods we
used to integrate spatial metabolomics
with spatial transcriptomics and ultimately spatial proteomics to start
identifying metabolic signatures of specific glioma transcription of
cell states that drive chemotherapy resistance and
resistance to therapy in general.
So for the spatial multi-omics approaches, we
designed a TMA that was built by a neuropathologist,
annotated core versus edge samples from glioblastoma.
We did this because different cell states are enriched in the core versus
the edge, and so we wanted to capture that diversity by separating them out in a
TMA. And this captured the three different grades of glioma,
Grade 2s, Grade 3s, and Grade 4s
diffuse gliomas. And we performed spatial multi-omics using the 10X
custom
probe set on the Xenium platform. We performed spatial proteomics
using imaging mass cytometry, and then we performed mass spectrometry imaging that
captured metabolites, peptides, and glycans.
So a lot of data from this study. And then we looked at
biological relevance using standard platforms,
GBMap, cMap, TCGAN, IVGAF, to allow us to annotate the cell
types on the tissue, differential gene expression that would then allow us to,
again, infer clinical relevance of differential gene expression between the core
and the edge, as well as cell-to-cell interactions that potentially were
associated with plasticity and resistance to chemotherapy.
But ultimately, again, as a clinician, my goal was to take all of
this data, a lot of data, but try to translate it into clinical use.
And the way we were trying to do it was to use a tool in the operating room that
will allow us to detect, again, metabolic
correlates of the different transcription of cell states, really focused on the
mesenchymal and the AC-like cells, or using IMC-derived Ki-67
proliferating cell data that's been fused to H&E to actually detect
proliferating tumor cells in different regions of the tumor in the operating room
without waiting for the steps that occur after sending a sample to the pathologist.
Again, as a non-computational biologist, I'm not going to spend a lot of time on
this slide. I'll
send you to my colleagues, computational biologist colleagues, some of whom are in
the audience right now.
But ultimately, we used the H&E to anchor a lot
of the studies that we did, including the Xenium analysis
for cell annotation. We also anchored our IMC
studies and segmentation to the H&E, as well as our metabolomics, our
MSI data set to the H&E segment. And as you
can see, the MSI is not really single-cell resolution, so we relied on MSI
intensity to allow us to colocalize to
cell types that were defined by the Xenium transcriptomics data.
And then we used this MasSpec Pen technology that we brought into the operating
room, thanks to our collaborator, Dr. Livia Eberlin at Baylor College of Medicine.
And she's been using this for several years to actually
use metabolomic signatures to distinguish normal ovary,
low-grade tumors, or high-grade tumors in the operating room.
And we started using it to test and differentiate between normal brain versus
tumor brain. But I felt like we could push this technology potentially further
by trying to use this technology to distinguish and derive signatures
of specific transcription of cell states enriched in different regions of the
brain. And this will allow us to be more aggressive in the regions that are
enriched for plasticity-associated transcriptional cell states or proliferative
cell states in the brain that were usually associated with chemotherapy
resistance. And so just going through some of our results
very quickly.
So you see here that across the tissue that we have in the TMA,
they segregate very nicely with the control spleens being off as
outliers. But here you see our Grade 2 oligodendrogliomas, our Grade 3
anaplastic astrocytoma, and our IDH wild-type glioblastoma segregating based on
transcriptional expression profiling.
We also compared the core to the edge of these tumors and
looked for differential gene expression
across the core and the edge. And again, for the sake of time, I'm only going to
focus on the glioblastoma data set.
And we found some genes that were differentially expressed at the tumor edge versus
the core when highly expressed, had clinical
relevance in terms of overexpression causing poor survival, either from
edge-enriched genes or core-enriched genes.
Again, suggesting that this subgroup of glioblastoma, IDH
wild-type glioblastoma, is a very heterogeneous group clinically, and now we're
using this data set to further stratify this IDH wild-type
glioblastoma group into more clinically relevant
subgroups that allows us to actually prognosticate a little bit better about
patients who will do well and patients who will not do well.And
then going into the cellular level, we looked at local regional cell heterogeneity
across all the diffuse glioma grades, and really nothing surprising in this
analysis. There are differences in the enrichment
of different cell types across different glioma types, going from Grade II to Grade
IV.
But as you go comparing the core to the tumor edge, we don't really
see unique cell types showing up in the core versus the tumor edge.
I'll show some changes in the proportions of the cell states across the core
versus the edge in specific glioma subtypes.
But ultimately, one thing that stands out is that myeloid population, which is in
orange here, is really the driving immune population in
glioblastoma and other low-grade gliomas.
And we barely see any T cells in these tumors, which really speaks to the highly
immunosuppressive microenvironments of diffuse glioblastomas and
gliomas in general.
So zoning in on just the glioblastoma comparison, the core versus the
edge, something that also stands out and gave us confidence that our analysis
was headed at least in the right direction was that we see that the
mesenchymal-like cell state is really enriched in the hypoxic tumor core of
these tumors, which is something that's been shown by several groups.
But as you go across the tumor into the edge, you start seeing normal
representation. Although this didn't reach statistical significance, you can see a
trend towards normal cells in the tumor edge, suggesting that these tumors,
again, within the core, are mainly tumor cells that are essentially
killing normal cells in the core, hypoxic, necrotic.
But as you go towards the tumor edge, you start seeing more
potentially dysfunctional normal cells in the tumor.
So the mesenchymal-like cell state, again, is implicated in the tumor core and
enriched in the tumor core of glioblastoma.
What about interactions? Cell-cell interactions have been shown to
drive plasticity and resistance to chemotherapy in
glioblastoma, again, using an organoid ex vivo system.
But we wanted to find out in real patient samples whether those
plasticity-associated cell interactions, the significant ones,
were enriched in one tumor type versus the other tumor type.
And I'm only showing the cores of the tumor here, we also have data for the edge.
But what we see is that the mesenchymal-like and the AC-like cell
states are in close proximity to each other, particularly in
oligodendroglioma and glioblastoma.
And again, this is important because that's the cell state.
Those are the cell states between which plasticity occurs during treatment and
drives resistance to chemotherapy and radiation
therapies. Just suggesting that our TMA, again, is capturing some of the
cellular interactions that are critical for responses to treatment.
I can't leave this talk without talking about immunotherapy and immune-related
microenvironment, because that's what we're all excited about.
Unfortunately, immunotherapy hasn't really worked for brain tumors, but
we're starting to have some insights based on spatial analysis about why
immunotherapy is not working. And one of the strategies we took was to look
at the contribution of the different glioma cell states to
immunosuppression of infiltrating immune cells.
And one of the major ones, like I talked about earlier, is the mesenchymal-like
state actually immunosuppresses macrophages and monocytes
that are infiltrating these tumors.
But it's really unclear what the other cell states, how they contribute to
immunosuppression. And when we looked at our data sets, again, looking at
glioblastoma, we first looked at the response
TGF-beta-induced gene, which is a response marker for TGF-beta
signaling. And we found that it was really highly expressed in
predominantly tumor-associated macrophages from a peripheral origin or
monocyte, suggesting that those cells are exquisitely sensitive to TGF-beta
signaling from the microenvironment.
And when we looked at where the TGF-beta was highly expressed within the tumor, we
found that TGF-beta 2 was actually coming predominantly from AC-like cell states,
secondly from mesenchymal-like cell states, while TGF-beta 1 was actually coming
from the myeloid population, so a paracrine/autocrine
signaling occurring here. This suggests that we're now implicating the AC-like
cell states in TGF-beta-mediated immunosuppression of tumor-associated
macrophages.
And so based on all this data that we've collected, the question is how can we
transition this or translate this into better clinical treatments and
approaches for patients with glioblastoma?
For one, our lab has been focused on generating genetically engineered
macrophages for several years, and we're fortunate to have a clinical
trial that's upcoming where we're testing genetically engineered macrophages
injected into the GBM microenvironment and seeing whether it actually improves
survival of patients. But we know that cell therapy doesn't really work in solid
tumors as well as liquid tumors, and part of the reason for that is the
microenvironment is so harsh for these cell therapies.
And so based on the spatial transcriptomics approaches that we've
taken in implicating TGF-beta receptor signaling, we're now
designing genetically engineered macrophages that will hopefully be resistant to
TGF-beta by using CRISPR-Cas9 to knock out the TGF-beta receptors
on these genetically engineered macrophages.
And this will hopefully allow us to use the genetically engineered macrophages to
create an inflammatory microenvironment, but they'll be resistant to the
crosstalk that occurs between mesenchymal cell states and
macrophages, or the AC-like cell states and tumor-associated macrophages.
And hopefully, these cells will be more effective at slowing these
tumors down as opposed to the wild type of genetically engineered macrophages.
We'll have data on that hopefully in the next several months.
And then finally, I think the more exciting part of this project for us is how
we're taking our integrated spatial
multiomics data and bringing it into the operating room.
And what we've done as an exploratory analysis is we've taken
and compared metabolites that are enriched in the edge of
glioblastoma. This is where recurrence typically occurs.
And we've cross-referenced it to data from Livia Eberlin's
MSI or mass spec data, which is the mass spec pen that we bring into the
operating room, and identified MS-PEN-detectable
metabolites from fresh GBM samples.
And following multiomic alignment and integration using the steps that I described
earlier, we're now starting to identify metabolic signatures of
each of these glioma cell states, some of whom, like I told you earlier, are
implicated in immunosuppression and chemotherapy resistance.
And we're also identifying, again, MS-PEN-detectable metabolite
signatures for Ki-67 positive proliferating tumor cells, where it
takes several days to get Ki-67 staining back.
We're building this data set to actually give us information about proliferating
tumor cells live in the operating room from samples we derive from patients.
And ultimately, where this is headed is we're now trying to validate this data
set by performing spatial multiomics on the
same tissue as opposed to adjacent tissue like we did earlier.
And so we're taking fresh GBM samples,
performing mass spec imaging, H&E staining, which we anchor everything in our
alignment to. We're using Xenium, actually, the 10x Xenium platform for
this, as well as IMC to correlate RNA to metabolites in the same
tissue to find out, again,
causation versus
correlation between these two platforms.So in conclusion,
diffuse gliomas remain an incurable cancer given the inherent resistance to
chemotherapy and immunotherapy.
Plasticity treatment resistance associated with mesenchymal-like cell states and
AC-like cell states are enriched in the cores of oligodendrogliomas and
glioblastoma. And we're developing strategies to make cell therapy
resistant to some of the crosstalk that happens in a glioblastoma microenvironment
based on this data. Local regional differences in gene expression may delineate
clinically relevant subgroups in a very heterogeneous IDH wild-type glioblastoma
based on the differences we're seeing in a core versus the edge.
And then what's really important and exciting for us is during brain tumor surgery,
the MS pen may be used to detect multiomic integration-derived metabolic signatures
of plasticity and proliferation-associated glioma cell state that allows us to be a
little bit more aggressive with certain tumors, improve the survival of these
patients based on how much of the tumor we can resect in the operating room.
And with that, acknowledging a very big group, some of whom are here, Dr.
Yang-Shih Ma, Dr. Nguyen, some of my collaborators who
are in the audience, including Dr.
Ye Zhang, and thank you for your attention.
Unfortunately, we're out of time, so I encourage everyone to find Dr.
Eide after the talk.
Yeah. Thanks.
Thank you so much.
All right, so our next speaker is Dr.
Ye Zhang, who's an assistant professor in Pharmac and Comp Bio at
MD Anderson.
Okay, so my work is on the opposite direction of my colleague's, Dr.
Nguyen. So I'm a computational biologist.
My goal is to develop a handy tool for you to
review the information in your data and to help
better treat the patient. So this work focuses on how to
harmonizing the single-cell proteomics data across
different assay, different technology.
So I will start with a particular technology for illustration.
So CITE-seq is a multi-omics single-cell
technology. It can not only profile the gene expression, but also
the cell surface protein profiled by this so-called
antibody-derived tag. So going forward, I'm going to use
ADT count to represent the cell surface protein
signal.
Okay? So the reason we want to profile additional modality
because for some sub-cell type, using the gene expression in itself
cannot give you a better separation, highlighted here,
but this cell surface protein is well-established,
well-functioning, so it can better distinguish the sub-cell
type and function. So after harmonizing them together, you can have
a better refined cell type and cell status
description.
So this is the data that CITE-seq technology will give you.
It will give you a big matrix of gene expression.
Rows are genes, columns are cells.
And at the same time, it will also give you this ADT count,
basically the protein measurement.
Rows are protein, columns are cells.
And because this is like a two modality measurement within the same cell,
so you can see the column have this one-to-one matching relationship to show
like, okay, those are the gene expressions, those are the protein on the same cell.
So the data pattern actually for the gene expression and the protein are
quite distinct. But when this data was launched, how to
analyze the protein data usually is derived directly from single cell RNAseq.
But again, the characteristic can make the direct
application of those computational model not very
appropriate. So for example, we all know single cell RNAseq tend to be
a little bit more sparse. You can see a lot of zero on the count matrix.
But for the
gene expression, zero meaning background, meaning the gene has no expression or
it's slowly expressed, it cannot hardly be captured.
But for the protein data, the background is not zero.
It's actually a readout, but it forms a so-called negative
peak. And let's dive into it. So for example, let's
take one protein across all the cells.
For example, we take this vector of count and then generate
its corresponding density distribution shown here.
So again, x-axis is a protein readout, the protein enrichment
signal across all the cells. So y-axis
is the enrichment of the cell, showing how many cell that have
the exact same protein count.
And one track is a sample. One color represent a
batch. So you can see the protein data actually give you a
two-peak pattern. So the first peak, we call it
negative peak, which shows a background, meaning that the cells
within this peak region has actually no protein enrichment
on their cell surface. They still have a readout because antibody
has specific binding characteristics.
So for example, the yellow antibody specifically to
bind to yellow protein, but the yellow antibody can also
specifically randomly bind to other protein in a lower
likelihood. So that's why it formed this background.
For the second peak, which is positive peak, those are the cells that really
have this protein on the cell surface. Okay?
So you can see for batch one to three, it has very distinct
two-peak pattern, very separable background from your signal population.
But for batch four, you see this overlap, right?
Meaning that background and signal power are kind of mixture with each other.
So we kind of suspect there are some batch effect in the data.
So that's why we project it onto a 2D visualization.
So one dot is a cell. So you can see if the cell came from the
same cell type, regardless of which batch you use to profile it, it
should form a close overlap cluster, like they cluster together.
But now batch four kind of form its own cluster.
It's kind of confirm, yeah, there are some batch effect in the data that drive the
cells apart.
So when this CITE-seq technology was proposed, it come with a
SeR normalization.
It's very straightforward, so it kind of take a geometric mean
across all the protein for one cell, and they try to use this
geometric mean to estimate the sequencing depth, like the library size
variation.
And then they try to get rid of the batch effect using the count
on
the matrix divided by this geometric mean and take log
transformation.But you can see there are many more
variations that can lead to this batch effect.
For example, we can use different concentration of antibody.
A higher concentration definitely will give you a better separation of
the signal population with your background population.
So all those potential reasons that lead to the batch effect are not
taken care of in this very naive
scaling method.
So that's why you can see, after SAR transformation, you can still
see batch four is quite unique.
And again, on this 2D visualization, again, batch four still form its own
cluster.
So that's why we want to think of how can we propose a customized
protein-specific integration model that can get rid of
all those heterogeneity in the data.
So showing here is if you want to integrate across different study,
different dataset, the variation is even more dramatic.
Like one row here is a dataset. They are designed for their own
specific study. So you can see some of the background can be even higher than
some of the positive signal here. So to get rid of those
very dynamic, very dramatic
batch effect,
we want to propose a very nonparametric way.
Because previously we are thinking how can we exhaust all the potential
reason to make them into a parametric model and
get rid of them in our data. That's almost impossible because the
level or the source of the batch effect is so
heterogeneous, due to the study its own.
So why not we just use a nonparametric way?
Why not we just identify all the background, identify all the positive
population, and then just do a transformation so that all the background align with
each other, all the positive signal align with each other.
And the data came back as if they came from the same technician's hand.
So we propose this model called ADT Norm.
It's like a normalization for the ADT count data.
A little bit more mathematic detail is the model start
with peak identification using curve registrations.
Basically, we get what is a negative peak, what is a positive peak.
And we also identify the valley. You can see there is a gray bar here.
That's a valley, separate out the background population and the positive
population.
So the final step is just to do a transformation using functional data
analysis-based model to align all those landmark,
align all those background signal, all those valley, and all those positive signal.
And now we get rid of the batch effect.
Okay, so as you can see,
we want the peak to align with each other.
Definitely they will align with each other.
And highlight in here is this dataset only have T-cell.
So for CD3 protein marker, definitely we only expect to have one peak.
So the ADT Norm pipeline can also take in this prior
information. Like you know there are some cell type proportion or cell
type composition specificity. You can just provide this prior information,
and the pipeline can handle and align this unique peak to the
positive peak.
Okay, so you can see previously, different dataset form its own
small cluster. Now they are more mixed with each other,
and they came from the same major cell type.
And definitely like to make this model more convincing, we benchmark
it with all kinds of single cell RNA seq, CyTOF, Ciseq
data normalization method. And we use a few
metrics to evaluate how much batch effect is left in the data
and how well the cell type can be separated due to this.
And a good method should be located around this corner, which is our method.
Okay. We use different evaluation metrics to evaluate.
Okay, so one bonus function is that we can also give you a
quantitative evaluation of your antibody staining quality.
So we can quantify how well the positive signal is separated
from the background so that you can know whether you need to adjust it,
your cocktail panel, or whether a certain protein
marker is just
non-rescuable that should be excluded from the downstream profiling or
analysis.
So this part of work has already been published on
"Nature Communications," so feel free to check it out.
So going forward, the ultimate goal is to see how can we
harmonize, go beyond one technology, and harmonize all those single-cell
proteomics data across different technology.
Because the motivation is that for large cohort, large study that
span 10 years, 20 years,
due to the technology development, they potentially start with flow
cytometry, CyTOF to collect the data, and later on they adopt
new technology, Ciseq, spatial proteomics.
But they are designed for the same study goal for the same
purpose.
So how can we analyze them together for this big
picture, for this
bigger goal, but using larger datasets instead analyze them on
its own? So that's our ultimate goal.
So the bottleneck is that different technology definitely give you a very
distinct data characteristics. And the way
to handle different parameter can be very tedious, very
messy. So for example, we start with integration between
Ciseq data and flow cytometry. And yeah, you can see
preliminary data give us this nice integration.
As long as there are some cell type overlap, some marker overlap, we can definitely
do this kind of integration.
But going forward, as we try to integrate more and more data, we
need to handle hundreds patient, hundreds marker, and each
protein marker may have its own parameter.
Each technology also have its own
most optimal parameter setting. So it will be very
painful for human to tune those parameter for its ideal cases.
So that's why we're thinking, like, "Yeah, tuning parameter should be a machine
job, automatic job," right? So we design a AI agent to
help us get rid of those
very tedious parameter tuning issue.So this is a
very initial design. This looks like what you will see on ChatGPT.
So with this, you can directly use natural
language to run this program. You don't even need to learn how to use
ADT Norm, how to tune the parameter.
You don't need to be expert on tuning ADT Norm parameter.
You just need to know whether the result that give you looks
reasonable. Do you see any discrepancy in the data?
And you just use natural language, just tell it if there is
an issue there. And we have designed all kinds of skill to taking your
query and then turn it into a parameter tuning,
so that the
agent can tune the parameter for you automatically.
Okay, so this is a showcase. So previously, we were handling
a very large data set. Each color represents either a
batch or a different data set, and it's very hard
to harmonize. But now with AI agent help, we
can now integrate them pretty decently with each
other and showing here are the cell type.
So it's like a bigger cluster usually came from a major cell
type. Now we are fine-tuning it. So
we are at a stage of testing our AI agent panel,
so we try to use more scenario to stress test
it. So if you have this single-cell proteomics data that
you don't know how to harmonize them, we are very happy to help you analyze
it and at the same time to stress test our pipeline
as well. Okay, so in the end, I want to
acknowledge my group, my postdoc, and the staff scientists
worked very hard
putting out this pipeline and also
huge thanks to my funding source as well. Okay.
Full talk. We have room for a couple questions.
Thanks.
Thanks for the talk. I was wondering, for the normalization
method that you're using, ADT Norm, did you
also compute how much biological
variability you are reducing, you are removing while
correcting for the batch?
So are you asking what kind of like-- How much-
So when you do batch correction, you're essentially reducing the
technical variability. But it's known that you can
also reduce biological variability.
So I was wondering whether you also
have some metrics that evaluated
this reduction in the biological variability.
Yeah, we have evaluation on the, say, cell type separation rate
at different level to see whether those similar
biological information can be harmonized.
But if you're asking whether there are biological information lost due to the
batch effect-
Yeah
... removal, yeah, definitely. Yeah, we
have to admit there are biological variation that get rid of because,
for example, if, say, it's a certain protein marker that is more
activated, it potentially have higher signal than the median
signal, but still positive population.
So what we want to say is that that depend on your goal.
So if your goal is more to harmonize them together to do a very refined cell type
annotation, then you don't care about whether it is
extremely upregulated, activated T-cell or
just ordinary T-cell. So just for the cell type annotation
purpose, we think it's fine to lose those
biological variation information.
But your goal is to compare, let's say, within cell type, whether it is more
activated or not, then definitely we should go back to the original
data to do the differential detection.
Okay, thanks.
Nice talk. So I may be missing what are you talking about.
I just
hear you say you use the ChatGPT.
Yeah.
So if yes, a little bit of detail about it.
What I mentioned is that the layout design by my student kind of
mimic what the design of ChatGPT web interface.
But beyond that,
the difference is, is that this is specific for the protein
integration, so there are a lot of skill that we design behind it
to help translate our query into the corresponding
parameter tuning or setting changing.
So, the large language model support behind it can be
ChatGPT, can be any open source large language model that can help
the model understand your language query.
But what will be implemented behind is those skill that we
designed specifically for the single-cell proteomics data.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I have a question about the
other proteomic technologies you mentioned, like Codex,
IHC, IMC, those kinds of technologies where
signal bleed is a bit of an issue, and I was wondering if you were
planning to maybe use ADT Norm embeddings, perhaps
correct or improve
clustering across these
technologies.
Yeah. We noticed that too, like there are some markers, they clearly
perforate and you attack it, and yeah, there is just
only negative peak left. There is no signal at all.
So in that case, definitely, and we can leverage the other modality data's
information. As long as they can be nicely integrated together, they can be
projected on the spatial information array.
So you can use that to either impute or borrow the other modality
information to infer either protein status or
the cell function. Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Zhang, for a wonderful talk.
All right, we have our last speaker now, Dr.
Kamal Laughal, assistant professor at TGen.
Thank you. Hello, everyone. So
today I'm going to present a computational
model for predicting
binding between MHC class II
and peptides. So before starting, I would like
to
thank key contributors to this work,
Mitik and Cameron on the bioinformatics side and
Jorge on the wet lab side. And in fact,
they are presenting very exciting work on Wednesday, if you're interested,
on cancer early detection. So why
the peptide MHC-II binding problem? Why is it important?
So to trigger
a good immune response, CD4 T-cell
activation,
the binding of MHC class II and the antigen is a
very important step.
Okay? And so that's what we're interested in.
That is one of the three main steps, I would say, that
is needed for a good
CD4 T-cell activation, which is very important
for persistent immune response. And this has
implication, obviously, on
cancer immunotherapy, vaccine design, auto-immune diseases, et cetera.
So that is to say the MHC-II peptide
binding problem
indeed has very important implications for cancer
therapy.
So why MHC-II as opposed to MHC-I in our
case? Why is it computationally more interesting?
In fact, MHC-II peptide binding is more challenging
computationally. And the reason is that
there is much more constraints on the MHC-I side.
And the binding groove is much less.
There's much less possibilities for the binding groove when it
comes to MHC-I than MHC-II. So historically, it has been more challenging
to predict MHC-II peptide binding.
And so there has been some work on the computational side
to predict MHC class II peptide
binding.
These are not the only ones, but the main
ones that we've been looking at are NetMHC 2.0, which is a
tool where you can input your peptide MHC and you can get a binding score;
MixMHC2Pred; and Maria, which is another deep learning-based model.
The main common point I would say to these models is that they are sequence-based.
They take a sequence as an input, and they learned
based on proteins as a sequence. So they do not look at the
predicted structure or ground truth structure, 3D structure of
the
peptide MHC complex.
And so there has been some work done previously on the structure
side
from the Phil Bradley group based on AlphaFold2, and
it was pretty encouraging, and it clearly showed
the potential of using
predicted 3D structures
for MHC-II peptide binding problem.
Okay.
So we are going to use three main tools in our approach.
Two tools that are AI foundation models.
The first is AlphaFold3,
which
predicts
3D structure of
complexes of proteins. This is the main advantage of
AlphaFold3 as opposed to compared to the previous model, is that it does
much better on
group of proteins as opposed to just one protein.
And then ESM2, which is an LLM language model on proteins.
And finally, we will use
PepSeq, which is a highly multiplexed binding assay
developed
at TGen by the Alten lab
to generate training data and to generate binding
affinity data and use these two foundation
models,
train
a new model on top of these foundation models using this training data.
Okay? So what is the approach and the main question that we are going to
look at is using these foundation models and the PepSeq assay,
is it going to be possible to at least reach the
state-of-the-art in terms of
binding affinity prediction performance with
much less data? And the main point is that we are going to use, in what
I'm going to present, a training data volume that is
roughly at 2%
of the other models that we have been
looking at and comparing to. And so why is it
important? Well, because you would imagine that when it will come to rare
HLA alleles, I will not have that
amount of data, and
using models that are data efficient
is going to be very useful in this case.
Okay?
So
an overview of the workflow is going to be the following.
We are going to use these
foundation models,
look at the peptide,
so the PepSeq binding assay as a training set,
and then we look at two things.
Okay?
So the first thing is we'll use only
intermediary features from AlphaFold3 without any additional training,
zero training, and take a zero-shot approach
based on a score that we design, and then look at the performance of
prediction.And then our main model, which is
a graph neural network that is built using
ESM2, the
LLM model
embeddings in the graph neural network, and AlphaFold features to
construct the graph, and then train the graph neural network on top of that.
Okay. So three main tools, as I was saying.
PepSeq, which generates a control run and
a test run, allowing to
compare relative abundance of binder peptides to
non-binder peptides for a given HLA.
And then AlphaFold as a structure encoder that we are going to freeze.
So to be clear here, we are not fine-tuning AlphaFold.
We are extracting the representation features of AlphaFold and training
a model, a graph neural network on top of that. Okay?
So the first
approach is the zero-shot approach,
and then
we are going to build a GNN where we are going to use
ESM2 embedding
as node features in the graph neural networks, for those who are familiar with the
graph neural network.
Right? Once we construct the graph, we are going to
evaluate our model,
using the IEDB CD4 epitope dataset, which
is
a widely used benchmark dataset for these models.
And we are going to compare to
NetMHC-2.0 Pan, Maria, the
zero-shot approach, the graph neural network that we built, and then
finally the combined model between our graph neural network and NetMHC 2.0
Pan, which is viewed currently as the gold standard
in MHC 2 peptide
binding prediction. Before going through the results, I would like to show
some validation results on the PepSeq
assay, because this assay is
unpublished, in fact, what we used here for this particular assay.
And here you start seeing evidence of
utility of the PepSeq assay, where we took the NetMHC 2.0
Pan orthogonal method and we tried to predict binders versus non-binders,
where the ground truth is the PepSeq-generated ground
truth. And you can see that clearly the AUCs are very far from being
random. And you kind of see a correlation with the size of the training
data in terms of HLA, for a given HLA, on NetMHC Pan
versus the
PepSeq assay. Okay.
So
now I would like to communicate the main...
This is the main slide, actually, the main results.
You can see that on the benchmark dataset, Maria was,
and if I have time, I'll say a couple of words about it, but it was clearly
underperforming the other models.
Then you would see the zero-shot approach that is referred to
as FCM, the Fisher
score here,
followed by NetMHC Pan, and then our GNN approach, again, using
2% of the training set. And finally, you get the best results once you look at the
training data.
You can see that
mostly,
we are outperforming NetMHC 2.0 Pan on the DRB1 alleles,
precisely because the PepSeq assays were run on DRB1
alleles here.
So the majority of our training data was based on
DRB1 alleles. We augmented our dataset
with,
again, less than 2% of the NetMHC 2.0 Pan
training database
for prediction on
non-DRB1 alleles and rare alleles.
And we are still within the performance of NetMHC Pan, even though you
clearly see a
flipping here, which makes sense because
PepSeq was run on
DRB1 alleles, as I was saying. Okay?
So that is the main. Now one
might ask, "Okay, you are saying that trained on 2% of the data, you are
doing as good as state-of-the-art.
But what if models like NetMHC 2.0 Pan can do as good
training with just 2% of the data?" So what we did was NetMHC 2.0
Pan is not open source. So what we did was,
we took the model as it was described in the methods section of the paper
precisely. We implemented the model,
NetMHC 2.0 Pan, and then we trained it exactly on our
training set.
And when we do that,
NetMHC Pan
has an overall AUC of 65%, which is
10% difference between our model trained on
the same data and the NetMHC 2.0 Pan model.
Again, so why is this important? Because one might ask,
"Fine, it's data efficient, but
this is not the main bottleneck. This is immune therapy.
I can run as much data as I can." So this is important
precisely because
once you will get to rare HLAs and data that is not seen in
training, data efficiency becomes very important.
Okay. Just to
open the discussion after showing these results,
I would like to mention one, I think, very
important behavior that we saw on the model and that might
guide to a direction towards improving the performance and see what's happening
with AlphaFold. So,
we have three main types of HLA: HLA-DR,
HLA-DP, HLA-DQ for HLA type II. And it has been reported
in the literature that
the epitopes, the positive, the good binding peptides that bind
to HLA-DP,
they tend to have reverse
orientation as opposed to canonical orientation when you look at
the complex constituted by the alpha chain, the beta chain of the HLA,
and the peptide itself.
And okay, but AlphaFold doesn't know that.And when you
look at
the AUCs of the epitopes
of the DR and DQ allele, you can see that when it's in the canonical
orientation, the expected one,
so AlphaFold is giving the
expected orientation. You clearly see an AUC that
is better
than the inverted one, and vice versa when it comes to HLA-DPs.
So this is an evidence saying that
the flaw is in AlphaFold there,
and it's hallucinating when it comes to the orientation of the epitopes.
It's not being very consistent.
And so
if we put together
all the epitopes, mixing the HLA and then sorting them into
expected orientation versus unexpected orientation, you see that the
AUC has high predictive performance
in the expected orientation case versus the unexpected orientation case.
So you would start thinking about
playing with this orientation to improve the model further, just to open
the discussion. And this is one of the future directions
that I wanted to mention. Other future direction, so obviously
peptide MHC-II binding is one step for the immune response.
Even more interesting to include the TCR, so
now you have a triad in the protein complex that you want to
predict.
Other directions, and Maria, the model that I
mentioned before, has the merit of doing so, is to include the gene
expression data and the tissue in the prediction,
because obviously to have good immune response before any binding prediction, you
need the antigen to be present, and you need
the protein to be expressed. And
finally,
more data intensive,
we would like to fine-tune, get the last layers of the
AlphaFold model and start fine-tuning, because as I was saying, the
GNN that was built here was based on frozen features from
AlphaFold. So there is no end-to-end backpropagation and
training. Last thing is,
after seeing how promising is the PepSeq data, we would
like to run it on rare HLAs now as opposed to
DRB1 HLAs.
And
I would like to
thank everyone. Thank you.
Any questions? Maybe one question if
the crowd.
That was a beautiful talk.
Thank you.
I love that somebody's working on MHC-II instead of jerking around more with
MHC-I. We see it as a huge contributor to post-transplant
relapse. So you mentioned antigen availability,
complex availability. How are you planning on looking into that
or augmenting your model to leverage
measurements of antigen availability and/or complex
presentation?
Mm-hmm. So yeah, the idea there
is to--
So what is it? You have a gene expression data, basically, right?
And then,
for every gene you can associate the
corresponding antigen peptide that you're looking at, and you will augment the
feature. You'll have to normalize, obviously, your gene expression data, and
then you add
that expression as an additional feature into the graph neural network, for
example, here. And there, the prediction, it wouldn't correspond to just the
binding prediction, but a good immune response in general.
Sounds like a cell surface metric with appropriate
normalization could maybe fit into that?
Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks for a great talk.
Thank you. Thank you.
All right, folks. We got to the end of the session. That was fantastic.
We saw quite a lot of different data integration methods.
I'll leave you with a question to take home.
As a community, now we have to think of how we bring all these data integration
methods into the clinic to make decision, to change clinical decisions
for the benefit of patients. So let's see how that goes.
And on that note, thank you so much again.
Please join me in, again, thanking the speakers.
Very good.